anyway okay guys well let's go for it so
gerrae
you're gonna bring us up to date yeah
so obviously a lots been happening since
since we we last spoke on this issue and
to some extent I guess what surprised me
was not the amount of lawyers and
paralegals and licensees that have not
only reached out but apparently written
to the Law Society on this statement of
principles issue but more importantly
the public I'm getting a lot of outreach
from the general public and you can look
at the the comments on the YouTube video
that we put up the general public is
concerned and they are very much
watching in terms of the legal actors
lawyers paralegals they I understand
there are a lot that have written to the
Law Society the types of people that are
reaching out to me are a broad
cross-section of the industry very
experienced lawyers very well
established lawyers constitutional
scholars are are doing their thing but
I'm also getting paralegals who sense
that there's a problem and they're also
writing one of the things that I think
has been interesting through all of this
is that the tone of the comments that
I'm or the feedback on getting has
migrated in first instance it was a
issue with okay yes this compelled
speech idea is sounds objectionable
those same people and some new people
are beginning to reach out and that and
the commentary is changing to some
extent it is now that they're beginning
to examine the underlying report itself
and they're coming to me with questions
about well what does it mean that that
the there is a systemic discrimination
and racism within the legal industry and
what's interesting is I've actually got
racialized licensees that are beaten
that are beginning to not only reach out
but also publicizing their opinions on
these things and and they're starting to
grapple with that larger question of
well what does it mean when our industry
is systemic
discriminatory so people are becoming
aware there's an awareness that's coming
about and I think a lot of that has to
do with with the media that's been
coming out in tandem with with what we
did on on YouTube yeah so the well in
the problem with the systemic racism
charge is that well it's vague that's
for sure and then it targets everyone
equally in some sense within the
profession and requires systemic
adjustment that's the other thing and
obviously has to be supported with hard
data and it isn't self-evident that the
data to support that claim is is valid
by I would say by any stretch of the
scientific imagination so I've had a
great deal of feedback as well from from
both lawyers and the general public and
they are of a mind I think as Jared
described about their concerns over the
forced speech aspects of this
requirement I think we should make note
of the kind of response that has been
generated from supporters of this policy
in response to the kinds of concerns
that have been raised and a lot of those
people who are insisting that this is a
legitimate requirement are saying that
well you know although it's called a
statement it is not forced speech it
simply governs conduct and if I might
I'll just read out a quote attributed to
the treasurer on this question that
appeared in the law times the treasurer
was quoted as saying with respect to the
statement of values this is a conduct
obligation to recognize that we have to
commit to these values and it's not a
speech obligation or a thought
obligation now just on the face of it
that statement seems strange to say the
least to say that what we have to do is
to commit and yet that's not are there a
a thought proposition or a speech
proposition today even you have to
commit
in a statement that indicate that you
have right so it begs the question of
what's the definition of commit Oh
correct yes and and the way that they're
portraying it is that this is simply a
an articulation of the obligations that
lawyers already have and both the rules
of professional conduct and and in the
Human Rights Code which which is clearly
not the case nowhere in the rules of
professional conduct or in the Human
Rights Code is there any obligation upon
anyone to promote anything well and also
if if we if you already have that
obligation then why is it necessary to
add this additional layer of let's call
it obedience yes well let's just let's
just note the the two the two
contradictions in the portrayal of this
on the one hand it is described as not a
big deal there are no immediate
sanctions to follow you don't have to
send the statement in you just have to
write it you just put it in your own
file so we're not worried about it it's
it's it's it's no big thing why are you
so concerned about it and on the other
hand they are emphasizing how central
this is to the project that they have
set out and and and there are many
people who have suggested essentially
that if you are not willing to do this
statement and indicate you are agreement
with a certain set of values then you
should not be allowed to be a lawyer and
practice in Ontario great well that
certainly seems to be the endgame and my
sense is being watching this that
because of the public pressure they're
backing off to some degree in their
public statements by moving forward into
the future at some indeterminate date
the actual sanctions that will be
applied so that right now from a public
relations perspective it looks like this
isn't a draconian measure and might as
well also remind people that mean they
might wonder while I'm here my concern
when I first encountered this was that I
know and I know with that sinking
feeling you get when you can predict the
future accurately and you don't like
your prediction that
if the Law Society prevails with this
that the rest of the professional
organizations in Canada will follow in
lockstep very very rapidly and will end
up in a situation where every
professional in Canada is required to
pen a statement of principles that are
essentially required by by their their
colleges espousing a particular
political and not only political but
philosophical and worldview philosophy
or risk losing their licenses and I mean
I know in the legal in the law society
already you have to there's a
requirement that you have to undertake
training in relationship to equity
diversity and inclusivity right that's
part of what they're requiring well
let's just read that out one of the
recommendations in this roster of
recommendations that convocation has
passed is recommendation nothing and the
third part of recommendation nine reads
as follows the Law Society will require
each licensee to complete three hours of
an accredited program focused on
equality and inclusion with within the
first three years following the adoption
of these recommendations and one hour
per year there every year thereafter
which will count towards professionalism
hours for that year so in other words it
is exactly as you described Jordan there
will be training now so that you have
the right attitude about these matters
right and I can just imagine what that
training will be like so MOU well there
was some commentary in the underlying
report about unconscious bias training
and and I know Jordan that you've you've
had some discussions about that and some
of your your public works yeah well
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that unconscious bias
training produces the results intended
first of all the relationship between
unconscious bias say as assessed by the
implicit association test which is a
pathological misuse of a psychological
instrument even the people who designed
it have grudgingly admitted that there's
there a relationship between those
implicit prejudices so to speak which
aren't even recognized universally by
psychologists as implicit prejudices the
relationship between them in any
behavior is very very small it accounts
for very little of overt behavior and
then the evidence that you can train
people out of those unconscious biases
is zero so this is this is misuse of
science and education at every level
from a scientific perspective it's the
inappropriate politicization of a very
new line of inquiry in social psychology
and if the people who designed the IAT
in my estimation had an ounce of of in
what would you say intellectual
integrity they would denounce the misuse
of their test because it doesn't fit the
requirements that psychologists have
laid down for validity or reliability
and that's partly why it's not
admissible in court for example so well
the committees that are selecting our
judges currently are being put through
unconscious bias training and so I
questioned whether or not the Law
Society will will heed the warning that
you just put out there but yeah it's
very unlikely and and so you know I've
already decided that with regards to my
clinical license if I was required to
undertake this kind of reeducation
program and to pan a statement of
principles of that sort that I just give
up my license so the only way I'm doing
that so the public that's the one thing
I wanted to let you know is that you're
not alone Jordan the the the the
groundswell of public feedback that that
I'm seeing and receiving directly into
my office has been significant people
recognize exactly what we talked about
on the last video that that the legal
industry and lawyers in particular are
supposed to be that that bulwark against
this type of overreach and so they
really very much there's a there's a
large segment of the population that are
worried they see that if the lawyers
fall down then the rest will fall can we
just make a note of one argument that
has been made in favor of the statement
which is that you know lawyers are
already subject to a a set of ethical
obligations and this is just one more an
extension of the same kind of idea but
there is a significant difference
between the kind of ethical obligations
that exist which are essentially neutral
non
political obligations that were late to
the way that our adversarial
adjudication system is supposed to work
so just for example every lawyer has an
ethical obligation to avoid a conflict
of interest you can't represent both
sides in a dispute because that would be
contrary to the way our our adversarial
system is supposed to function that
doesn't that doesn't make any sense you
can't represent both sides in a dispute
but that ethical obligation doesn't have
political content doesn't matter whether
you are a socialist or a conservative or
a classical liberal or anywhere on this
political spectrum the the if you are
functioning in this legal system it only
makes logical sense that you must
proceed without in the absence of a
conflict of interest which is this
substantially different proposition than
the proposition that these requirements
are based on which are as as Jordan that
you mentioned earlier these are
politically charged and have substantive
political content in them the law
society is essentially saying that
unless you adhere to a certain ideology
that you are not fit to practice law
well it's also an admission that this is
and this is I think the more perhaps
even the more dangerous element of this
is that to undertake re-education with
regards to your political beliefs
surrounding or even factual beliefs
surrounding equity diversity and
inclusivity is to act out by implication
the fact that you need that re-education
because you're part of the problem of
systemic racism and you know it's very
it's very psychologically significant to
act out an admission of your guilt
because what happens is generally
speaking is that people then
retroactively Lee alter their self
images and start to wonder about such
things you know because they're either
cowards for for going along with thee
with the requirements or liar's for
producing a statement of principle that
they don't actually agree in or they
start to tilt their beliefs in the
direction that's required by that
demands and that's usually what happens
and so and I'm quite convinced that the
people who do this sort of thing who
make these requirements know that and
that it's a it's a manipulation on their
part to tilt political belief overtly
and so it you can't act these things out
without it having psychological
consequences and and consequence it's
moral consequences let's say so it's
like very intrusive the the other thing
Bruce it's important to remember is I
mean the dichotomy between belief
thought and conduct currently lawyers in
Ontario are subject to the rules of
professional conduct and and I right now
we have an obligation to act in a
certain way and to refrain from acting
in other ways and one of the rules of
professional conduct is you know thou
shalt not discriminate and I don't think
anybody would argue with that in that
out shall act in accordance with the
with the human rights regime and and
associated codes across Canada nobody
could argue with that
but this statement of principles is
crossing the line into thought and
opinion and and one of the
recommendations I would note in the in
the report is recommendation number one
they're actually proposing to review and
amend where appropriate the rules of
professional conduct the paralegal rules
of conduct and commentaries to reinforce
the professional obligations of all
licensees to recognize acknowledge and
promote principles of equality diversity
and inclusion now I find that
fascinating because you're gonna you're
going to amend a rule of conduct to to
include all of a sudden a an affirmation
of thought and to insist upon promotion
as well because obviously very
ill-defined yes so with let's just go
back to the words just just to make this
point so again I'm going back to a a a
quote attributed to the Treasurer in the
law times piece he says this the
statement of values is an obligation to
promote equality diversity and inclusion
generally which is nothing more than the
obligation lawyers have already but when
you go to the rules of professional
conduct it says a lawyer has special
responsibility to respect the
requirements of
rights laws enforce in Ontario and to
honor the obligation not to discriminate
on the grounds of race has to be place
of origin color etc etc that's exactly
as you just said Jarrod this describes
an obligation to observe the law and
though and this law consists of
prohibitions that is the obligation that
lawyers are under no doubt about it that
they must do so but that is not include
an obligation to endorse and it is not
include an obligation to promote right
and we should also point out just in
case it needs to be said that none of
the three of us disagree with the idea
that people shouldn't be discriminated
against for reasons that have nothing to
do with their competence agreed agreed
if not what this is about and it might
also be useful to talk for a moment also
about the word equality use equality has
two competing legal meanings and and the
law society has not defined which one of
them they mean explicitly but it's clear
by implication which one they mean and
the two choices are formal equality or
substantive equality or support equality
of results and the two things are quite
different formal equality simply means
that the same rules of conduct apply to
everybody regardless of background of
wealth
lineage of heritage and so on same rules
apply to everybody in the same way
equality of results means that everybody
ends up in the same place and and note
that these two ideas of equality are
diametrically opposed and inconsistent
with each other because if you have
formal equality applying the same rules
to everybody because everybody is
different you're going to have different
results for everybody if you insist upon
the same results from everybody that
means you need different rules for
everybody for them to end up in the same
place so you cannot have both formal
equality and substantive equality
together and traditionally the rule of
law has included the notion of formal
equality right you have a properly
functioning rule of law that means you
have the same rules apply to everybody
without regard to who they are well the
problem with it with equality of outcome
which is now often termed equity is that
you can group people each individual in
the multitude of different ways and it's
impossible to produce equality of
outcome across all those different
dimensions of the comparison so it's a
never-ending struggle to produce
equality of outcome it's it's
technically impossible and and societies
that have tried that have had well it's
been absolutely catastrophic and their
noses terribly divisive it is also
contrary to that fundamental legal
proposition that justice is blind
justice is supposed to be blind to all
of those personal certain
characteristics that one has whether
it's race or color or gender or wealth
or background or lineage or or political
connection whatever it happens to be a
properly functioning judicial system
doesn't take account of who you are it
simply takes account of the rules that
exist and tries to ensure that that rule
those rules are enforced equally in the
same way with an even hand against
everybody and this so-called well the
data that has been generated is also
predicated on the implicit acceptance of
an equality of outcome doctrine because
the fact that every group isn't equally
represented at outcome is in the data
point that's being used to indicate
systemic racism that's right yeah and so
the so then you also think well what if
you what if you're in a situation where
as a professional and an informed
professional you don't agree with the
with the conclusions drawn from the data
set that there is indication of systemic
racism I mean is that now a belief that
you don't get to have because if you are
forced to write this statement of
principles and alter your conduct then
you're acting out the proposition that
you accept the conclusion that the
reason there are some differences in
representation across groups is because
the enterprise is the whole legal
enterprise is systemically racist and
thereby you're also thereby admitting
your own culpability in relationship to
that
and the corruption of the entire legal
system and that me that you should be
required to admit to that if you don't
agree with it and that's the arc of the
commentary as I mentioned at the outset
is that it started in one place and the
feedback I'm getting now is very much in
that place that people are beginning to
question okay what does it mean the
findings of this report for me
personally and for my industry and and
what does the data say say and people
are digging down on it in fact I just
read an article the other day that said
that there's actually been a doubling in
the representation of racialized
licensees within the industry between
2011 and 2014 you know that's not
something I think a lot of people
recognize is that yes the well the
report may may have touched on something
in terms of findings there's also some
things to celebrate well the other thing
too is that you have to specify in a
report like that if you're going to
consider this something approximating a
scientific investigation with you and it
wasn't conducted in a manner that would
meet those requirements in my estimation
that there's going to be a lag in ethnic
representation as the population
demographics change because the
demographics of the population from
immigration are going to change more
rapidly than the representation of
people in in the professions just
because of the necessity for the new
immigrants to take time to be
incorporated into the culture and so the
real point of data should have been the
rate at which newcomers are being
integrated into the profession rather
than the absolute numbers of people who
are there already and that's
self-evident and so the fact that that
isn't being considered deeply in that in
the data is also indicative in my
opinion of the political slant of the
interpretive framework through which the
data was analyzed we also make note of
the irony of the way that the word
diversity is being used and the means by
which are being used to promote
diversity because in a sense the
objectives of these recommendations is
the opposite of
diversity real diversity genuine deep
diversity is diverse includes diversity
of thought mr. Dave pinion diversity of
worldview diversity of ideology
including all the other seeds of
diversity and diversity is a very very
important thing for a pluralistic
society you if you don't have diversity
in a pluralistic society then you you
must be living under some kind of
tyranny right because everybody is
different and everybody deserves to be
allowed to be different and to think
different things and to behaved in
different ways as long as they don't
encroach upon the rights of other people
but but the the vision that seems to
allow underneath these provisions is a
very singular one a vision that
everybody will think and adopt
progressive values that a proper law
firm consists of a group of
progressively thinking lawyers that that
look like a rainbow also there's there's
an appalling proposition underneath that
- that's actually factually incorrect so
the fundamental racist proposition is
that racial groups differ sufficiently
so that you can identify them as
separate entities and that they should
be treated in that manner but the data
suggests very very strongly that even in
situations say like where men and women
differ in temperament on average that
the overlap between men and women is
larger than the differences and the
difference is within the groups so the
differences between women and the
differences between men within their own
groups are larger than the differences
between men and women so you don't get
true diversity by selecting across
groups that isn't how it works
in fact that's actually a fundamentally
racist or sexist claim right down to the
core and two predicates to assume that
what you get is diversity of opinion by
selecting for diversity let's say of
race is well first of all it's wrong
that it's just technically incorrect and
second I don't see how that's
distinguishable from the claims of the
Jim Crow types of the 1950's who said
well you know black people and white
people are so different that they should
remain segregated it's like they're not
that different so and and but within
groups they're very different but
between the groups they're not that much
different the differences aren't aren't
like the differences between men and
women aren't non-existent but even then
you wouldn't select on the basis of
those differences to produce diversity
of opinion so but it's not the diversity
of thought model that that organizations
are including our own governments are
pursuing at this point that the law
society is not alone in that in assuming
that that people who all think alike but
that have different racial or gender
backgrounds is in fact diversity I mean
the Ontario Securities Commission has
been mandating that type of diversity on
on boards of directors for publicly
traded companies you know that the
federal government and in its cabinet
appointments is is pursuing that that
type of diversity that really is not a
diversity of thoughts so to speak or
opinion but a diversity of one in the
federal government's case gendered yeah
well the other thing that's gonna happen
is that if we you know that people who
hold the political views that are
pushing these ideas forward are
convinced beyond beyond argument that
what they're going to do is to what the
instantiation of these policies is going
to result in is increased racial harmony
and let's say harmony between the sexes
but I think you can make a very strong
case for exactly the opposite which is
the more that we define people by race
and gender the more that people are
going to be defined by race and gender
and I don't see that at all I really
don't see that as a recipe for social
harmony I don't think it's worked in the
United States at all
quite the contrary and we actually have
a pretty harmonious society already by
any reasonable standard any reasonable
world standard and I think that this
will inflame tensions between groups
unnecessarily well well I actually had a
lawyer reach out to me a racialized
licensee and say exactly that that their
main concern with what they were seeing
not only in the compelled speech
component on the statement of values but
also the underlying recommendations of
the report is he thought that that was
going to inflame tensions or animosity
towards people in his group and and I
had never thought of it that way but he
was quite concerned that this was
actually going to to generate animus
against those that actually sought to
protect so that's a debt that's one
viewpoint that I hadn't hadn't expected
so should we discuss for a moment the
motion that is being brought to
complication a joke Roya who is a lawyer
an adventurer has put together a motion
to change the nature of the statement of
values requirement and perhaps I'll just
read it the key provision of this motion
moves that convocation approve that no
licensee who has a conscientious
objection to the adoption of a statement
of principles shall be required to
comply with recommendations 3 1 and they
shall be exempted from the requirements
of recommendations 3 1 to adopt and
abide by a statement of principles now
Joe is it as a fellow that has my utmost
respect he's he's done a great deal of
good inside complication I think as as a
venture and I admire his willingness to
put forward this motion which means he's
sticking his head up in from a crowd
that doesn't really want to stick their
heads up absolutely but nevertheless
they're there there are some
difficulties with the motion Jared do
you want to speak to that first well
yeah so the motion itself I somebody was
talking to me about it and they said the
problem is is that it makes it appear
that if one elects not to file the
statement of values so if you if the
motion is passed and they they then
decide I'm not going to file the
statement of values on that basis that
you would be seen or it would be
interpreted as you being a conscientious
objector to the values that the Law
Society statement of values is asking us
to affirm and and it rather than an
objection to this idea of compelled
speech or being forced to disclose or
divulge what may be in your head or what
your thoughts and opinions may be and I
and I hadn't thought of it that way but
when you look at the motion yes it very
much can be interpreted that way
right and so in essence it does not save
you from having to to perform the forced
speech obligation just gives you another
thing to indicate which essentially
requires you to stick your head up and
and be counted one way or the other in
other words the law society is still
succeeding at dividing people between
those people who are willing to do the
statement and those people who refuse to
do it but have to say that they refuse
to do so there there is still force
speech in here even if the motion passes
yeah I don't think it gets us to where
we need to be you know and as you said I
think Jose Jose a tremendous person
deserves a lot of respect he's fighting
his own free speech battles before
before the Supreme Court of Canada and
early November as you may know he was
accused of crossing some imaginary line
about the conduct of his defense of an
individual before the courts and and
that is a very novel idea and so the
industry is watching with some interest
to see what the Supreme Court of Canada
says about whether or not there is a
line in the sand that's the type of
advocacy can pursue so he is a Joe as
somebody to watch and someone respected
but I think the motion comes up slightly
short of where it needs to be I don't
think it gets us to the place that I
think we need to be which is that the
law society should not be met meddling
or even asking what the what the
thoughts and conscience is of its
members right so as of right now there
is nothing sort of on the table that in
as far as we are we are concerned that
that offers the possibility of
eliminating the objectionable aspect of
this forced speech obligation on the
phone it's interesting
go ahead Hren okay well we'd also talked
a little bit about the fact that you
know we had concentrated specifically on
the statement of principles as the
objectionable element of the
recommendations but recommendations as a
package are also objectionable because
they're all fed by the same underlying
philosophy of
well systemic racism let's say and and
that promotion of equity diversity and
and equality as the highest of moral
values so do we want to talk a little
bit about the rest of the recommendation
so yes sure yes let's well let's let's
I'll read out the the first one perhaps
the first one I gives a flavor for the
whole the whole host of them so the
first one goes like this the Law Society
will review and amend where appropriate
the rules of professional conduct and
the paralegals rules of conduct and
commentaries to reinforce the
professional obligations of all
licensees to recognize acknowledge and
promote principles of equality diversity
and inclusion consistent with the
requirements under human rights
legislation and the special
responsibilities of licensees in the
legal and paralegal profession now
though there are those words again okay
so you also mean if you abide by that
that you have to accept the definition
of diversity as essentially predicated
both on race and sex yeah well yes well
of course they haven't defined diversity
but it consistent with the rest of the
regime yes that that in in the way that
we have previously described that that
is the meaning of diversity that they're
going for right and also the meaning of
equality like so and of course there are
internal contradictions in the statement
because they're going to amend the rules
of professional conduct so as to
reinforce obligations that don't now
exist what they really mean to say is
we're going to change them so as to
create new obligations the requirements
under twin rights legislation that this
recommendation refers to again do not
include the obligation to acknowledge
and promote they are they are conduct
laws that everybody is subject to but
they prohibit certain things so so like
the statement this first recommendation
that gives the flavor of all the rest of
them it suggests that the the Law
Society is essentially moving into a new
area area
of regulating competence if I can put it
this way
instead of being a a neutral regulator
of competence in the political sense
they have now more or less taken on the
mandate of regulating competence in in
the political sense in the ideological
sense they are essentially saying here
are some values that a regulator is
going to require you to comply these
values essentially are progressive
values so that if you are not a
progressive lawyer we do not think that
you have the right to practice law in
this progress and as the only values
that are going to be the subject of a
statement of values they are elevating
those to a position of prominence and I
would suggest beyond all others yes sure
these these these values because of
their their illicit in a special way
seem to be put above other more
fundamental values like the rule of law
like formal equality like like
competence or like it's like well
competence you would think would be the
core mandate of the law society itself
and by competence I mean skills
knowledge and compliance with ethics
professionalism yeah well I miss this
also seems to me to be reflective of a
constant push on the part of political
ideologue of the progressive type to
mandate that of all the rights that
Canadians enjoy or perhaps the
obligations they have to undertake that
the rights of the the the rights that
are associated with equality diversity
and inclusivity are going to be made
paramount in relationship to all of the
other rights and that seems to me to be
an utter catastrophe so well the
proponents of the of the statement of
values the people that I've seen writing
commentary pieces none of them seem to
disagree that there is a compelled
speech component inherent in the
statement of values what they do is they
say okay but under Section 1 of the
Charter and an Oakes test analysis that
infringement on freedom of conscience
thought freedom of expression is
reasonable to attain the objective of
equality which is also a competing right
under the Charter and inevitably and I
think they have a point any time the
Supreme Court of Canada is engaged in a
section one analysis on freedom of
speech that that butts up against the
competing equality right they tend to
find that save and except for the most
egregious infringement that the Equality
right shall prevail or be the the
tipping factor and so it's it's int like
I said it's interesting that the
proponents they don't disagree
oh yeah we're putting a compelled speech
component on you but it's it's always
justified let's just also note this
though because the first part of section
15 is it really a section about formal
equality leave the equal application of
laws to everybody which is not the kind
of equality they're talking about so
they are they are shifting the ground on
what equality means and then staying and
that kata kind of equality justifies the
infringement of these of these other
rights in under Section 1 as you say
okay so do you want to continue Bruce
yes so so let me let me read another one
let me just find it here I want to read
the one here we go
this is recommendation 10 this is I want
to read this one because it just
reinforces the proposition that we spoke
about which is that the law society is
is changing the nature of competence to
encompass a certain set of political
values so they're doing this explicitly
recommendation 10 says as follows the
Law Society will include the topics of
cultural competency equality and
inclusion in the professions as
competencies to be acquired in the
licensing process so if you are along a
young lawyer a young law school graduate
and you are applying to be licensed by
the Law Society then these are among the
things that you must show to them that
you are competent in that you look you
you believe and agree and follow these
particular values it'll be on the bar
exam yes
yeah shall I continue on yeah there's
the there's the the same I believe I
read out already the requirement for the
continuing education matter let's let's
move to one of the recommendations that
are being put in place this year the
statement of values is is one and the
and the other one that is mandatory for
work legal workplaces of over ten
lawyers goes like this the Law Society
will require a a licensee presentative
of each legal workplace of at least ten
licensees in Ontario to develop
implement and maintain a Human Rights
diversity policy or their legal
workforce addressing at the very least
fair recruitment retention and
advancement which will be available to
members of the profession and the public
upon request okay so there there's a
measurement issue because a measurement
and enforcement issue so the measurement
issue is well what is fair and how is it
defined so is it defined by the racial
makeup of the firm over the next ten
years so if it doesn't shift in the
required direction let's say or the
gender makeup of the firm it doesn't
shift in the required direction does
that mean you're out of compliance like
the details in this sort of the
measurement details and this sort of
thing really matter who defines fair and
then what's enforced and who's going to
like it are this are the firm's going to
be subject to an external analysis that
it examines their their diversity makeup
over some period of time and is there is
there going to be provisions about how
rapidly the the ethnic and sex makeup of
the firm has to transform across time
the Devils in the details in this sort
of thing they're proposing actually that
that a member of the workplace conduct
an inclusion self-assessment every every
two years
to get at the measuring component and so
what's an inclusion self-assessment mean
exactly what do you think that means
does that mean that what do you do do
you lift list
race me do you do do you examine your
soul to determine whether your you're
oriented in the proper inclusiveness
direction in relationship to race and
gender like I don't understand I'm a
measurement guy fundamentally you know I
don't understand how these things are
going to be assessed they're not easy to
assess and then there's the enforcement
problem if I really don't know what the
word inclusion means I have ideas about
what equality can mean I have ideas
about what diversity can mean I don't
know what inclusion means I I really
just don't understand the word I don't
know how you measure it I don't know
what you mean by that
the law society's been collecting data
for four years on these types of
demographics on the basis of a a
voluntary survey basis and so what they
are actually proposing to go further is
that within these legal workplaces
that these workplaces conduct inclusion
surveys now there was a tremendous
amount of conversation at the
convocation meeting that adopted these
recommendations about compelling people
to self-identify with in some sort of
demographic group or the other and that
there would be some there's there would
be some risk resistance particularly
among racialized licensees of doing so
so they're going to make it voluntary
but that then goes to the issue of
what's the quality of the data that
they're getting Jordan if it's a
voluntary self reporting exercise and
not everybody's reporting because as
they said at convocation some groups may
be disinclined or fearful of identifying
themselves for whatever reason what's
the quality of the data they're getting
and then how are they going to act on
that data yeah or maybe even unwilling
to identify themselves well that's what
I think I don't see why why it's it
should be required of me that I reveal
my well which aspects of my identity
what am I going to reveal so I mean
obviously I'm white whatever the hell
that means so but there's all sorts of
other aspects of my identity that for
example I might want to keep private
even the existing data on which they
found
the finding of systemic discrimination
the empirical data was based on
voluntary survey data so it were not
even certain that we're getting what I
would say is confident since census type
quality data so till I read you another
one of these recommendations
recommendation 12:2 says that the law
Society will revise the rules
professional conduct and the paralegal
rules of conduct where appropriate so
that systemic discrimination is clearly
identified as a breach of Professional
Conduct requirement would you say that
say that it yes yes I I will the Law
Society will revise the rules of
professional conduct where appropriate
so that systemic discrimination is
clearly identified as a breach of
Professional Conduct requirements okay
so that means that at some point in the
future a law firm could be assessed for
its compliance with equality however
that's defined perhaps as equality of
outcome but we don't know or with
regards to rate of transformation of
demographic membership and if you're
found not to be in compliance whatever
that means then that means that you've
you've engaged in professional
misconduct yes but interesting that they
use the word systemic discrimination
because I thought that meant we're
talking we've used that term in the past
to talk about the profession and that's
the way they use that term in the report
that the profession has a problem of
systemic discrimination so I'm this
puzzling over the use of that term in
this particular recommendation because
it suggests that if you are or your firm
is is guilty of systemic discrimination
then that is a matter of reaching your
does that does that mean that every
single lawyer in the firm is guilty of
that because that's what systemic would
imply yes I don't know it also begs the
question of how many people you need to
be systemic ly racist before you
actually have a system well they're
going to be doing a benchmarking
exercise I mean that's part of it is
that you're going to have to submit
inclusion assessments to the law society
and then they're actually going to
review that as against the industry as a
whole in terms of finding out where
you're at on your inclusivity and so my
concern would be that they find systemic
discrimination within an organization
because it falls short of of what the
industry rights wide standard is in
terms of its um well its diversity layer
mandate right and so what that'll mean
fundamentally is let's say that you have
a firm that has that it's a small firm
say ten people and all of the people in
it happened to be Caucasian just for the
sake of argument so got it mean that
you'll be mandated to hire by race for
the next while well your systemics
you're just under it's a systemic ly
discriminatory organization i think how
is that legal
how is that possibly legal to be
mandated to hired by race only by virtue
of the mandate that the Law Society has
from the government to regulate the the
legal profession I mean that that that
what it has to rest on if if you read
the the statutory mandates of the Law
Society it would seem to fall outside
the marching orders that the Law Society
has at least as it is presently worded I
can perhaps I can read you that this is
this is a section 41 of the Law Society
Act I sorry let me read first section
4.1 this is the function of the Law
Society is to ensure that all persons
who practice law in Ontario are provide
legal services in Ontario meet standards
of learning professional competence and
professional conduct that are
appropriate for the legal services they
provide so unless you can fit this into
the phrase Professional Conduct then
then under this section there is no
mandate to do these kinds of things I
was going to read section 41 which lists
the standards of professional competence
that the Law Society is supposed to
ensure and section 41 says a licensee
fails to meet standards of professional
competence for the purpose of this act
if and there are a number of things
listed but the
ones that are relevant here are a if
there are deficiencies in the licensees
knowledge skill or judgment or the
licensees attention to the interests of
clients and those are the only two bits
of that section that applied to this
question and they don't apply they don't
describe the nature of these obligations
that are being contemplated okay so if I
was if I was applying for a job at a law
firm that was compelled by this mandate
to diverse itself diversify itself
racially and I was a qualified candidate
and I got wind of the fact that that
requirement had been put in place
couldn't I go after the firm for
discrimination because they made race of
one of the basis of hiring that they
were compelled to make race one of the
basis of hiring the the Human Rights
Code and the Charter of Rights and
Freedoms allow for certain forms of
discrimination when it's a it when it's
for the purposes of an Amelia Amelia to
exercise for instance if there is
systemic discrimination identified the
Charter will permit discrimination
against a group in order to remedy what
it may be perceived as a systemic
discrimination issue this I mean
specifically addresses and exempts
affirmative action type programs as
being found to be discriminatory it
allows them it permits them so the
answer would be yes you could raise that
but the but the law firm and the Law
Society if they would have to then bring
forward evidence that this is part of a
you know an affirmative action type
program that is exempted and all that
you're allowed to discriminate on that
basis we for a moment just turn to one
of the justifications that have been
given for this whole slate of
recommendations this whole program which
is that your your membership in the Law
Society does a voluntary thing you don't
have to belong to the Law Society this
is not the state coming down and
requiring all its citizens to do a
certain thing you have chosen to be a
member of the Law Society and therefore
you must take these obligations on
voluntarily which of course is is a
ridiculous thing to say
because the Law Society takes its
mandate from the government the
government has has given the law society
the job of being the gatekeeper of the
of the right to practice law and if you
are to practice law in this province you
you must be a member and you must adhere
to the rules of conduct that they that
they require the Socialist Attila to
suggest that that your that your your
engagement with the Law Society is
something that you do voluntarily just
because you wish to do so and that makes
it a voluntary organization it is innate
right so the voluntary aspect is that
you can give up your hard-won livelihood
if you don't want to be subject to these
rules yes so I suppose you could make a
case that that's voluntary but I mean
it's it's certainly the case that it
stretches the it certainly stretches the
definition of what normal people would
consider voluntary well it turns it
turns the idea that you I you would have
a you would have a right to practice in
any profession if you have the proper
skill and training and competence to do
so that question is is up for grabs now
because they're essentially saying well
actually what you also have to do is go
along with our vision the way things are
to be and the way you're think and if
you don't choose to go along with that
way well then you're free to go off and
do something else and one of those
values migrated over time so it is right
now you know these these values that
we're looking at in the statement of the
principles here but what if they migrate
over time what could they become you
know and I think it sets a precedent
that that we might want to push back
against well then it's worrisome because
the values are very ill-defined and so
an ill-defined like a box that could
contain anything ends up containing a
very strange number of things and you
know Bruce pointed that out very clearly
when he talked about his inability to
understand what constitutes inclusivity
it's like okay so let's say that we
could we could define
quality and diversity if we were willing
to even using racial and gender
categories which i think is an
unbelievably catastrophic error but okay
inclusivity
well if that's definition less then it's
a place to put any other requirements
that might come along I don't know I
really can't say what in what is
inclusivity mean is that more like the
nonverbal behavior that you might
manifest you know or or or is it does it
refer to more subtle interactions within
the firm that's kind of what it sounds
like I'm going on so yeah so at least it
might be worthwhile trying to find out
what they mean by inclusivity if they
really want to be inclusive they would
get rid of the bar admission exams they
would get rid of the loss loss school
run during recording inclusive doesn't
it when you get well barriers get
suspicions to is that if you went and
analyzed the success rate out with
regards to the bar exam that you'd find
that it produced systemic discrimination
as well because the probability that
that an objective test produces exactly
the same results across all conceivable
groups is zero so and you know you see
this sort of thing happening in the
United States already where competency
requirements produce group differences
especially if you analyze enough group
differences and so what happens then is
the competency requirements are
gerrymandered to eliminate the group
differences so and that's all part of an
assault I would say on the idea of
objective competence so look are there
are there more are there more statements
that are worth analyzing let's just have
a look here I mean is that there's a
whole a whole roster of them but I think
those are the ones that are most
pressing well well I thought there was
an interesting one it was it was
recommendation 12
well sub 4 we want they want to create a
specialized and trained team to address
complaints of discrimination now I mean
I don't argue that
discrimination any act of discrimination
that is you know the contravention of
human rights legislation should be
stamped out it should be it should be
identified and dealt with but my
understanding is that we've got bodies
that are responsible for that already
not only the Superior Court but also the
the Human Rights tribunals so I wonder
what that I mean I read that and I say
that that's a SWAT team there's a SWAT
team that's going to swoop in on the
non-compliant systemically
discriminatory organizations and sort
them out that concerns me to some extent
particularly like I said because we have
this we have these bodies already in
place that are supposed to deal with
these types of things and they're
duplicate bodies so you have the classic
court system plus the on tier plus the
Human Rights tribunals well that's which
already have their own problems the the
word in that recommendation that causes
me real concern is the word address this
this team will address complaints of
discrimination now that doesn't say
whether or not they are the investigator
or whether they are the adjudicator or
whether or not they are a combination of
the two whether or not they are judged
jury and executioner all rolled into one
I would be much more comfortable if they
were procedurally precise to say exactly
what the function of this so-called team
was supposed to be but what I mean
what's it for we've got a Human Rights
Commission that can come into any
organization or workplace in Ontario
without a warrant and do this whatever
it is these this this group wants to do
so I questioned creating another layer
of bureaucracy but well I agree I agree
but what I mean what one of the needs
for this might be because of the point
that we made earlier which is that the
requirements that the Law Society is now
creating are are not the same as they
are under the Human Rights Code right so
the Human Rights Commission and tribunal
might not have jurisdiction because
that's not what the Act says and if if
these do would create extra and
additional requirements that are not now
don't apply to lawyers then you do need
an extra bureaucracy to to enforce them
because nobody else has to section to do
so right and then you can pursue I think
without any fear of error that
the people who would constitute such a
team would be the ones who would be most
zealously in favor of precisely this
kind of progressive let's call it you
what exactly oh yes definitely
that that's how it works so what well if
they're in favor of compelled speech and
think that that's justified then I would
question what other fundamental rights
and freedoms they they might deign to
stamp stamped upon all right so maybe we
should move from this one of the things
we discussed was perhaps asking for more
public involvement in our campaign let's
say and so I believe that we're going to
provide contact information for the
benchers is that correct and and ask
members of the public to listen very
carefully to the discussions that we've
had and to indicate to the benchers
their concern about this in terms of its
relationship to the broader public
potential relationship to the broader
public that the law society is is
mandate is to is to govern the
profession but within the I guess the
best interests of the public to protect
the public and so the public very much
is a stakeholder in what's happening
right now within the legal industry and
the Law Society and so absolutely I
would encourage the public to to make
any concerns that they may have known
and write to the people that make these
decisions and let them know their
thoughts because this is this is
something like this is a public trust to
this industry to some extent and so the
public very much as it should be vested
in what's happening yeah well it's a
fundamental public trust because it
deals with the underlying structure of
the legal system and so it this is
partly why this is so worrisome to me
because I know perfectly well that if if
the lawyers fold on this and the law
society succeeds in and pushing forward
these requirements and then and then
enforcing them across time that every
professional organization in Canada is
going to follow suit and after that well
once the professional organizations
follow suit then there's no there's no
reason to assume that this isn't going
to spread more widely so the the
the main justification underlying all of
this that the Law Society is relying on
is the Public Interest so if if the
public doesn't think this reflects their
interests they had better say so and the
licensees obviously anything they can do
to reach out I think is of some
assistance I think the current motion
that's before the Law Society is to a
great extent a byproduct of that
groundswell of support or opposition I
guess you'd say from lawyers and
paralegals and if they can direct those
efforts and and continue them I think it
can be of some assistance all right so
we broadened the the scope of what we
regard as worthy of opposition partly
because the attempts let's say so far to
ameliorate the worst elements of the
policies that are being promoted are
insufficient for the task and even if
they were put into place like the motion
that you described it would be a victory
at 10 percent or something like that and
and not not move the underlying
pathological principles in my estimation
far enough it's something like that it
wouldn't eradicate the threat that we've
been trying to warn people about correct
that that's right there there is no
immediate prospects right now of getting
rid of the forced speech element of this
policy and the other elements are
consistent with that that requirement
and are being carried along and and
although only three of these
recommendations are being put in place
immediately
the rest will follow into course and
there's no reason to think that they
won't be done aggressively and endless
forced
all right well I guess do you guys have
anything else to say
I mean maybe thank you to the people
who've already been paying attention and
well let's just thank the people who
have gone ahead already
and and contacted their ventures
contacted the Law Society to to register
their objection to ask questions a lot
of people have done very good things and
and are thinking well about this they're
thinking intelligently they're thinking
broadly they why my hats off to them
there there are a great number of people
who are very clear about this and some
are reticent to make too much of a fuss
some are quite happy to say what they
think and I respect both of those
positions but but I guess the message
overall is there are great many people
who think this and the the that the
worst outcome would be that nobody acts
upon what they think and this just sort
of happens without us noticing
I've been heartened by by what I see to
be singular acts of courage and the
people that have taken action written to
the Law Society and even just reaching
out to to my office and and to others
it's not easy to do and and I you know I
I support and and commend those that are
doing that and people have written
people have written articles and and
blog posts there are some really
excellent pieces of work on this topic
and perhaps we could even refer
provide links to some of those sources
but but they're really worth reading
they're very well done very thoughtful
pieces and they have a ring of truth to
them from all over to then from outside
I've seen stuff things from outside the
jurisdiction Alberta I think New Zealand
there's a great there's a great blog by
a professor University of Auckland in
New Zealand who's written on this it's
well worth of reason yeah well these
things do have international
significance because my observation has
been that if one major jurisdiction or
organisation in the West moves forward
in this hypothetically progressive
direction the probability that it will
spread because of
electronic communication and pretty
decent organization on the part of the
people who do push these things forward
that it that it emerges everywhere with
extraordinarily we're extraordinary
rapidity so anyone who shares the basic
axioms of our legal system is is
involved in this whether they like it or
not right all right well I guess we'll
see what happens
and maybe we'll provide an update again
in a couple of weeks